rescue teams resume work despite the
rain and strong winds they had halted
efforts on Thursday due to bad weather
the hilltop location and tough terrain
are hindering operations
the height of the site is around 950
meters from the ground and the Trek from
here is about 2.8 kilometers we're also
facing the huge challenge of not being
able to carry heavy equipment which is
why everything is being done manually
several bodies were recovered after
Thursday's Landslide about 60 kilometers
from Mumbai houses have been flattened
and Street submerged and dozens are
still missing
heavy rains have also battered the
neighboring state of Gujarat some areas
are submerged isolating villages
Rising water levels in dams and
overflowing rivers are raising concerns
about flooding
the water has entered our houses and
everything is damaged there is water
everywhere inside shops and in houses we
have suffered a lot of losses as the
water came suddenly from the nearby area
Monsoon rains remain well below normal
at the start of the season in June
but heavy rains this month have led to
flooding across several regions
in the last two weeks Capital New Delhi
witnessed the worst flooding in more
than 40 years and it's not over yet as
officials are forecasting heavy rain in
the coming days
ra